oscar inoa is going to come on and start
the game for the braves two different
splits jeff for huascars you see his
season numbers
the era is low because he's done such a
great job in relief but in his two
starts
again you give up a couple runs and you
pitch two innings your era is going to
take some punishment and that's been the
case for the braves young right-hander
the nationals have a runner at third
with one out
well that's a solid sound
drifting back cocuna junior all they can
do is return it to the infield that's
victor robles tags and heads home nets
on top
very quickly
will crow first time against atlanta
last start was his first career start
august 22nd against the marlins gave up
four runs only two of those were earned
over three and two thirds six hits two
strikeouts two walks two out walk keeps
the door open for marcelo zuna line
toward left that ball is fair headed for
the corner freddie around second
chugging for third the ball dies in the
corner freddie's gonna get waved around
hellman flying here he comes he'll score
standing up and ozuna launches a double
the left to tie the game
that turned into an rbi ben because josh
harrison waited way off the line for the
ball to come back to him like he was
going to come out of the corner
hard and it didn't it got hung up in the
corner and in the padding and he had to
go get it that gave freddie an extra
base first and third two down for brock
holt so now brock holt comes up still
looking for his first hit as a national
swung on it hold line to the left that's
gonna be a base hit his first hit
international's uniform scores josh
harrison from third taylor to second and
the nationals have the lead again here
in the second inning it's now washington
two in atlanta one
holt's second run batted into the year
is first international's uniform
so will crow has the lead with riley
duvall and camargo coming up this one's
hit high in the air toward left holt's
on the run to the warning track to the
wall goodbye halfway up the bleachers
for austin riley
a game-tying homer
austin reilly with his seventh home run
of the season it must have gone about
three-fourths of the way up into the
seats and left so back to the top of the
order to ronald acuna and he hit two
home runs in game one of the double
header today fly ball hit well this is
deep to center field this one's going to
challenge the wall this one is out of
the ballpark
ronald acuna with his third home run of
the day his first of this ball game
he rounds the bases for the eighth time
this season and the braves have a 3-2
lead
good chance for the nationals here down
by a run they have the tying run and go
ahead run in scoring position for eric
thames swinging a line drive fair down
the right field line it's cut off before
the corner by duvall cabrera scores
suzuki headed for the plate freeman's
relay throw the slide the tag and he is
in there
well that turned out to be a much closer
play at home than anybody thought but
it's a two-run single for thames and the
nationals back in front of the seesaw
fair four to three the nationals quickly
have the bases loaded for michael taylor
oh he crossed him up the ball gets by
darno to the backstop here comes things
he'll score
defoe to third and to second goes garcia
and jackson threw a fastball and that
one handcuffed darno and on the cross up
the nationals add a run and lead five to
three 3-2 to taylor swinging a hard
ground ball past the third baseman riley
and down the line and this will clear
the bases scoring his default right
behind him garcia and into second is
michael taylor the nationals played two
more they've scored five in the inning
and they lead the ball game seven to
three kyle finnegan will come in with a
basis loaded one out
and austin riley to the plate
representing the tying run swinging a
ground ball diving stop it short by
turner to second for one garcia the
first two a double play
oh what a play by turner diving to his
backhand that starts the inning ending
six four three double play and kyle
finnegan will celebrate his 29th
birthday with a big pitch right there
freddie freeman's never hit a grand slam
but he's got a chance here they're
loaded with one out swinging and a drive
to deep center field back goes robles
could it be the first one it is his
first grand slam and we got a tie game
freddy just launched one into the
bullpen for his first career grand slam
and he's got a big smile on his face as
he comes down the third baseline turner
is hitless in this game bounce to short
struck out looking and bounce to short
breaking ball well hit
see
you later trey turner's ninth of the
year the nets on top 8-7 and gets his
first hit in game two and gives the
nationals a lead again
a soaring fly ball into left center
field
it's the nationals eight and the brave
seven the nationals have runners on
second and third with nobody out here in
the top of the seventh inning swung on
hit in the air to center field acuna
there to make the catch the runner tag
suzuki coming down the line to score the
throw will go towards third a two run
cushion here at the top of the seventh
inning travis star know the batter if he
reaches the tying run comes to the plate
fly ball left that'll chase holt back
look at that ball carry still going to
the wall he won't get
has
it
a two-run homer
up up and away she goes it's a one-run
game
right now hudson trying to strand that
tying run in scoring position foul tip
into the glove of suzuki strike three
and bang zuma curly w is in the books